Hey Thoughty2 here.
In 1978 paleoanthropologist Andrew Hill was
throwing shit at his colleague when he discovered
one of the most important pieces of evidence
to ever support the theory of evolution.
Hill and his colleague were avoiding doing
work by throwing elephant dung at each other
at an archeological site in Tanzania.
Hill dove towards the ground to narrowly avoid
a large dung projectile hitting him in the
face.
As he slammed into the ground he noticed something
peculiar within the dirt of the excavation
site, a trail of footprints.
These incredible footprints that had been
perfectly preserved by hardened volcanic ash
were found to be 3.6 million years old.
They had been made by some of the very first
upright-walking hominids.
Up until Hill's chance discovery the oldest
human footprints we had found were only tens
of thousands of years old. 3.6 million years
ago when these footprints were made, our ancestors
looked remarkably similar yet so very different,
than modern man.
Australopithecus is the name science has given
to the specimens found from this period of
human's evolutionary timeline.
Australopithecus looked profoundly more apelike.
Compared to modern day humans, they had far
smaller brains, a protruding large jaw and
stubby nose.
The progress mankind has made physically,
in what is relatively, a very small amount
of time, is mind-blowing.
If evolution carries on at this rate I should
have superpowers in no time.
Where's my x-ray vision and superior hindsight?
But along the way something happened and evolution
was stopped in its tracks.
Human evolution has progressed so remarkably
fast, Earth is 4.5 billion years old and in
only a tiny 7 million years, which equates
to just 0.15 per cent of Earth's history,
humans have evolved from a primitive apelike
ancestor to a walking, talking, intelligent
being.
Well, most of us anyway.
But this rapid physical and mental change
within our species was caused due to immense
environmental pressures.
For the vast majority of humankind's history
and our ancestor's, we have not been predator's
like we are today, but prey.
Only with the advent of weapons and technological
advancement have we risen to the top of the
food chain.
Many early fossilised human remains have been
found all over the globe that have fatal wounds
made by animals, such as tigers, leopards,
and even by an eagles' talons, as was found
to be the cause of death of the 2 million
year old "Taung Child" skull.
So both physical and mental adaptation was
necessary for our species' future survival
and prosperity.
Rapid changes had to be made so we were better
equipped both mentally and physically, to
fend of predators and find food.
And so evolution showed no signs of stopping.
But then we went and ruined it all by saying
something stupid like "let's build a homogeneous
civilisation."
In 3100 BC Mesopotamia was built, the first
human civilisation.
Huge advances were made in farming and humans
no longer needed to forage or hunt to survive.
As the centuries have passed we have, on average,
all become wealthier, better medicated and
gained easier access to food.
The pressure to adapt to our environment disappeared
and so did the rapid evolutionary progress.
Today not only the fittest and strongest pass
on their genes to the next generation, but
everybody does.
This is especially true in the West, with
modern medicine and food at our fingertips
whenever we desire it, even the most stupid
and weakest members of society will pass on
their genes and that they most certainly do,
even if said individuals don't know exactly
who's genes they have passed on, one only
needs to watch five minutes of Jeremy Kyle
to understand what I'm talking about.
So in developed countries at least, there
is no natural selection anymore.
Sir David Attenborough himself said that "We
are the only species to have put a halt to
natural selection, of its own free will.”
Attenborough predicts that physical evolution
in humans will eventually cease completely
and we will instead go through a process of
cultural evolution, in which we will evolve
mentally.
So whilst survival of the fittest may no longer
hold true, survival of the intelligent certainly
does.
As each generation builds upon the wisdom
of those before them, intellectual growth
will speed up exponentially.
Today a person's survival depends not on whether
they can effectively hunt prey but whether
they can secure a good job to buy food for
themselves and their family.
It has thus become more important than ever
that people are more intelligent and more
creative than their peers.
There are only so many jobs in the world and
this fierce competition to be the best, climb
the ladder and steal more prestigious jobs
from others has put an evolutionary pressure
on our minds.
The Flynn effect is the observation that over
time average IQ levels have increased, substantially.
Since 1904, when IQ tests were first used,
the average IQ level across the globe has
increased every single year, in a linear fashion.
Every few years IQ tests are completely re-written
and intentionally made harder so that the
global average always remains at 100.
If you were to take an IQ test from 80 years
ago you would find it significantly easier
than a modern day test.
Human evolution has not stopped, far from
it, but it's goals have changed.
Mental acuity is now the next target of natural
selection.
So it looks like that X-Ray vision might have
to wait, shame.
So we're evolving culturally, although that's
very hard to believe looking at the current
state of contemporary music.
But what about physically?
Is this really all we're getting?
Has humanity peaked ascetically and mechanically?
Well, that may not be entirely the case.
It's generally accepted that evolution has
been slowing down since the dawn of human
civilisation.
But we shouldn't be so quick to put a definite
end on physical evolution, after all, mutations
don't occur overnight, they take tens, sometimes
hundreds of thousands of years to take hold.
And, if we look really closely, we have actually
changed physically, in recent times.
Despite getting more intelligent, over the
past 30,000 years our brains have shrunk,
from an average of 1,500 cubic centimetres
to 1,350 cubic centimetres.
Blue eyes are a prime example of evolution,
until just 10,000 years ago, blue eyes did
not exist, everyone had brown eyes.
But 10,000 years ago some unknown patient
zero near the Black Sea developed a genetic
mutation that turned their eyes blue.
They passed down the blue-eyed mutation to
many others and very soon blue eyes became
extremely popular, for an unexpected reason.
Blue eyes were an early form of paternity
test.
Men would often prefer female partners with
blue eyes because the man would know that
if his wife had a blue-eyed baby then it was
probably his.
If the baby had brown eyes, then someone had
been a little naughty.
Studies have shown that most men find blue
eyes more attractive than brown and it's thought
that this unreliable historical paternity
test could be the reason.
Of course we now know that eye colour genes
can be passed down through several family
generations and even if both parents have
blue eyes, it's still possible for them to
give birth to a brown-eyed baby.
So I imagine throughout history a lot of unlucky
women were incorrectly accused of cheating.
But surely one of the best ways we have evolved
in modern times is that humans have become
naturally more resistant to diseases.
Even when we have food on the table and good
healthcare there is one environmental pressure
that hasn't left us alone since the dawn of
time.
One of the world's biggest killers, malaria.
Over one million people die from malaria each
year, mostly in sub-saharan Africa.
But in 2007 a study found a group of 1,800,
previously undiscovered genes that have only
become prevalent in humans in the past 40,000
years.
These genes make us more resistant to various
diseases, such as tuberculosis, leprosy and
even malaria.
And it's predicted that these genes will only
become stronger and more prevalent within
the human race in the future.
Evolution has conquered hunger, and within
the next few hundred millennia we may even
conquer disease, for good.
Thanks for watching.